you can create the zero zero one and ft
which authenticates your piece but then
you authorize another ten and you let me
buy one of those so i can actually own
an image the real thing the one of a
kind dial to create
watch nfts
[Music]
all right let's talk about watches then
because i i always found that i always
liked it i mean from when i was a kid i
was like the the look of
um either on on some people you'd see
the classic leather strap
and some people i like i love seeing you
know like that traditional steel sub
look that you that became so like i i
love that look there we go what do we
got is that where we're in here
white face daytona black you know dial
that's the classic steel white face
daytona with a red band my signature red
band the band is nice man are you a fan
of like uh richard milde do you get like
those and you get some of those crazy
ones too yeah you know right now i would
say you know if we're gonna go down the
rabbit hole on watches there are two
there are two uh living watchmakers that
have reached picasso status
roger smith and fp journey and they make
watches by appointment journey is
a legend a living legend imagine if you
could have a michelangelo be alive and
come and paint a dial for you that's who
he is he only makes 900 pieces a year
there are thousands of people waiting
to get one from him they appreciate by
400 percent the minute they walk out the
store
if you ever flip one you never get to
buy another one from him it's you really
have to prove you're a collector to join
the german society it's crazy stuff
but and i've got a lot of jordans and
you know to me
it has nothing to do with telling time i
somebody said to me how can you even
tell the time on that watch i said i
don't this is a piece of art this is
it's a piece of art and it's appreciated
in value just like art does so my watch
collection is up 114
in the last 12 months
um
i have them stored all around the world
and i'm working on a really interesting
new deal that i'm funding to create
watch nfts
so that you know one of
i mean to me i mean i if there's anybody
going to do it it's going to be neat me
nobody knows the collectors like i do
nobody knows the brands like i do and i
can hire tech guys which i'm doing
i'm going to call this thing the wonder
trust
watch for it okay yeah so nfts i mean
it's you know it was something that i
don't even know if it was in the lexicon
a year or a little more than that ago
and now it's non-stop it's all you hear
about is all the possibilities of nft so
you're obviously a proponent of that
yeah well let me give you a reason why i
have a friend let's call him bill you
know these collectors don't like to
they're very quiet about their pieces i
went to his home recently and with a
lube i looked at a one-of-a-kind piece
only one only one in the world maybe
five other people have ever viewed it
personally i'm one of those five and i
said to bill look bill
can i get a picture
of this dial just so i can have it he
said no i've never let anybody
photograph it for obvious reasons that's
when the whole idea hit and i said bill
why don't we partner up and create an
nft company so that you can create the
zero zero one and ft which authenticates
your piece that's given stays at the
peace the rest of its life but then you
authorize another ten serialized zero
one through ten and you let me buy one
of those so i can actually own an image
the real thing the one of a kind dial
and what's the price auction it i'll pay
whatever the world's willing to pay for
it
that's where i'm going with this idea i
like the idea a lot um are you a fan of
patex too oh yeah patek is like
you know
patek is is is
if you think about the major brands that
you can't go wrong with adam rpk
paquette
you know piquet
or patek and then uh
rolex for sure i mean rolex makes
millions of watches but certain rolex is
the ones you want to go after but then
you've got the you know
you've got the micro brands like ming
i have a one of a kind ming no one's
ever heard of ming unless you're a watch
collector then you go out of your mind
to see this watch it was made for ming
it's a ming for me
and his production manager was a huge
shark tank fan i reached out it's in
singapore and i said listen i've heard a
rumor that ming's making a ming for ming
he said yeah it's a one of a kind that
said i'll buy it.
and he said i got to talk to ming and
maybe ming will want you to have it and
he did i have the only one wow
that's pretty awesome yes i mean look
i'm like i'm giddy like a teenager here
now i'm gonna turn that into an nft
i didn't realize that um patek did the
thing that i mean you see from different
types of manufacturers especially like
high-end luxury things where you go in
the store and you're like i want to get
the what's the uh the green
uh face oh the nautilus you're talking
about the 57-11 which just got you know
what happened the 57-11 the classic blue
dial was this that was the entry level
patek
and it exploded i mean maybe you bought
it for 30 grand the minute they canceled
it i think it was 150 000. now i'm lucky
to have a 57-11 but they also have the
last of the 57-11 which is a green-faced
version of the same nautilus and grown
men are weeping to get one yeah i love
that watch but i didn't realize that
when you when i was in this in this
store they go oh you have to
own other ones
for us to even like get you that one i
was like oh okay let me tell you
something the chance that you'll own
that watch is zero cool put you to set
you up you're gonna have to deal with
all the collectors around the world that
have millions of dollars of pateks ahead
of you that's the thing you've got to
understand patek understands the value
of their collectors and there's
something else you should know patek has
relationship with royal families
all around the world they don't talk
about it but certain royal families when
a child turns 18 what do you think they
get a one-of-a-kind patek
wow so when you think of um
your collection
and and like the you know the magnitude
and the value of it ultimately as you
get older is that something you go i
want this to my kids is it so you'd want
auctioned off is it something you wanted
shown like a museum style what's like
your ultimate dream for your watch
collection yeah i've been asked that so
many times including from phillips which
is the world's number one watch
auctioneer they do it every fall a huge
uh
you know charity auction which i
participate in and also the auction
watches i've told my family that's
always raiding including my wife who
loves to wear all my watches and my
daughter and son i say listen guys
all of these are coming in my coffin
with me i'm not eating anything
and so and the reason i'm going to need
all this is i'm going to a place where
it's a really really long time we're
talking about i'm going to need really
good watches and my wife said me don't
worry kev i'll bury them in the case
don't worry
[Laughter]
so your collection is hundreds of
watches i'm assuming or maybe
you know what i've learned because i've
had two heists over the decades and so i
no longer disclose how many or where and
i have a very complex
inventory control system a really
complex insurance system in place but
that's why i'm so motivated along with
several other collectors to start this
nft company because all of us that have
these massive collections are going to
create these nfts in association with
giant insurers because we we want the
manufacturer to authenticate our serial
number and we want the insurer to ensure
based on location but you know my
watches they'll never be a heist again
because
they're in so many different countries
and so many different vaults all over
the place well congrats on that you know
my one of my agents worked out like a
really good deal for me on something and
um and then when i was talking he was
like how happy are you with this deal i
go very happy and he goes cool you're
gonna buy me a watch and i was like what
and he goes yeah i'm a collector so
that's your that's what you're going to
do not so easy not so easy to get
watches these days as an asset class
they've exploded to the upside even for
example the
recently a standard six thousand dollar
rolex just you know that the entry level
rolex they put out a bunch of colored
faces one of them was a
coral red face on a six thousand dollar
perpetual
and kanye was seen wearing it at a
basketball game and gave it to his
soon-to-be divorced wife i guess kim
kardashian on television the watch
exploded it just
every woman wants this 41 millimeter
entry-level coral red it's just insane
well that's another thing that happens i
went to i was in vegas a few weeks ago
and you know walking through one of the
nice casinos and they have every type of
store and i went into the like one of
the high-end jewelry stores just you
know looking at watches
they had their inventory was abysmal
like they had like
two of these and two of these and i'm
like where else do you have this they
don't have any watches in retail there
are none you're going to have to deal
with your representative and you know
rolex is sold out patek sold out adam
rpk sold out even omega sold out
everything's sold out
okay well good to know guys uh you got
to know someone to get a watch now let
me ask you about big we're talking about
big ticket purchases one thing that um a
lot of different couples families talk
about is is when there's a big purchase
made is there a discussion personally
i'll just buy something and show up with
it and then my wife's like how much was
that i'll be like it was this much and
then she'll be like oh my god and i
don't i don't
talk about it ahead of time um but some
people have lengthy discussions about
whether or not a purchase should be made
and i'm wondering if you have an opinion
on that yeah it's an interesting
observation because i did a book i wrote
a book once i did a lot of research on
called men women and money i ended up
writing three of them on this topic and
then that first book which took i
thought it would take me a couple of
months to write it took me over a year
and a half i did a lot of research with
divorce attorneys and i found out
something incredible it doesn't matter
what you know economic level you're
talking about fifty percent of unions
break up between five and seven years
not for infidelity
most marriages can you know survive
infidelity
it changes them somewhat but they can
survive what they can't survive is
financial stress
the majority of breakups have to do with
inconsistencies in one couple spending
habits versus another that puts the
family under financial stress that's why
the union breaks up it's just hard too
hard to deal with because really a
family at the end of the day after seven
years is a business you basically both
have to have common goals you have to
save commonly you can't get into debt
too much and sometimes people are
incompatible they never did any due
diligence going into the marriage about
that and so really you know when i tell
people look if you're dating and you're
going on your third date time to start
some financial due diligence about your
potential partner in fact you're getting
together for a third time must mean
something
and so you know it's worth asking um i
mean i love the romantic part of any
relationship but at the end of the day
if you're losing money and you're
putting your partner under tremendous
stress and you can't support your kids
in your home
you're going to get divorced
yeah i mean i guess you're right i mean
i i feel like the um probably the most
stressful time
in my own marriage was um those early
years we were struggling the most right
because you're just
it keeps you up at night how are we
gonna pay for this you know yeah yeah i
remember when i got married i couldn't
even afford uh any dinner for our guests
or anything we just ordered in pizza and
i said listen stay tuned i think i'll
figure something out i'll have a party
in a few years when i can afford it
which is basically what we did but it
was really tough for the first four
years
yeah and then those i mean for us god i
like i would say
the first
the first few years were those were
absolutely the hardest we were living in
a terrible neighborhood in a horrible
apartment and and you know even like
when we would i would i sold something
like this uh web thing and i got a check
for it it was
like the day before a bill came from the
city for like a new tax and i was like
oh [ __ ] and it was you know thousands of
dollars and like it felt like you
couldn't win
but you know on the other hand if you
can make it and you're with the same you
know partner you had all those years
that's equity you've built in your
relationship i'm still married to my
wife the one that we had no money and
she's never been impressed with money
she just doesn't care and so you know
it's not what makes her happy she just
wants to take care of the family and you
know
it's it's just it's really refreshing
actually to find that out i know she
didn't marry for marrying me for money
because they didn't have any so that's
good to know
you feel like um
uh
when it when it comes to
a lot of times when you're
coming up right you think about a sum of
money as being enough
and you know somebody might say like oh
you know you have no money they go oh a
million dollars or whatever and and then
you achieve that and and make many times
more that people a lot of times look at
people that have achieved
success
at a high level and they have you know
more money than they think they you
could ever need or spend
and they go why do you keep working
and i always
think that it's because
well a like what else are you going to
do but also because you get the thrill
out of
the deals and the competition and you
know trying to make it work and seeing
it work again it's not so much that like
oh i have this much more money now i can
buy something it's like being in the
game
yeah i what i i would say to that i've
tried retirement you know most
i've talked to many entrepreneurs that
that have had big liquidity events i
mean mine was the classic start in the
basement
10 guys one day we wake up our company
gets sold for 4.2 billion dollars
yeah i mean it was you know
we all showed up the next day back at
the office saying what do we do next i
mean you know we didn't know anything
else except working and and even though
i woke up and said [ __ ] i'm really rich
and but it didn't change anything but i
decided well maybe i'd like to go around
the world and visit every beach
like just there's a project let's go
visit every beach the ones in cambodia
vietnam north coast of cyprus all this
stuff which i did for 36 months
was that ever boring like i was going
out of my mind and and so i just said i
got to get back in the game i you know i
got to get back in the game and so i
just started doing deals again not so
much as an operator but as an investor
the people that are successful
do not
pursue
money for the greed of it they they're
never successful if they try that if
you're after money because you're just
greedy you'll never have any but if you
have a real passion about a business
you'll wake up one day like i did say
wow how'd that happen because it's it's
the pursuit of personal freedom
that is what sets you free it's it's
that you
you're driving you know your business
because you love it so much you want to
compete and once you know one day it's
worth a lot of money and somebody buys
it
and that sets you free and then you
pursue the things that matter uh to you
um and that's what i do i i you know i'm
i'm very fortunate that every day i you
know i have this woman i work with him
nancy chung breaks up my day into blocks
and and every week at the beginning of
the week i look at the week and i say
what's this over here on thursday at
three she says yada yada i said i'm not
doing that
i don't care who they are or what they
are i don't care i don't want to be rude
tell them no i'm not doing it it doesn't
interest me and you know it's my time
i'll cry if i want to and i don't i
don't have to do it and so
i want everybody to get to that place
it's a very fulfilling place to be
that's a that's i think that's great
advice i know that um people ask me
about you know
stand up and i always tell them
that the only thing i know for sure
about
achieving some success in that field is
that you have to have a level of
obsession about it
um especially in the first you know 10
plus years like if if what matters to
you is
having success in those years i've never
seen it work it's just people that are
in love with the process
of writing and performing and getting on
stage and all those people that were
obsessed and didn't care if they
couldn't make rent and all their friends
were buying their first homes and all
this stuff and you go like i don't give
a [ __ ] i just i love stand up all those
comics
that i know are the ones who achieved
success
yeah that's a very dark profession i had
a chance to travel
while shooting at documentary as a
cameraman once
with a group of standards a lot of drug
addiction a lot of alcoholism there yeah
it's great it's a really tough uh
tough tough tough business because
you're on at night you've got a lot of
crazy people in the audience and it just
grinds on those clubs in la in chicago
been there done that
to survive that you've really got to
have some kind of an instinct of uh you
know you gotta care so much about what's
going on on stage i mean because other
people that people do succumb to the
drugs and the alcohol and everything all
the temptations of it but the ones who
like i consistently go like yup that you
know that that person's totally made it
they they cared so much they were so
obsessed
with performing comedy that nothing else
mattered and then
you know all of a sudden 10 and 20 years
later
achieving all this great success and
people are you know it's funny when they
they go he's an overnight success or
like just came out of nowhere it's like
i'm well aware 20 years there are no
overnight successes in the comedy space
it's brutal i you know i've always
thought that the the best perch would be
to get your own night show on television
or something which there's only five or
six of but the travel is the food is
terrible the travel is brutal i mean
travel the travel is what kills you it's
like the um like that old i think i
think it was gene hackman said it um i
might be getting it wrong but he said uh
um
the i act for free it's the waiting
around that you pay me for you know on
movie sets
and uh i feel the same way about stand
up it's like i'll do the show for free
it's all this brutal travel that i'd
like to get paid for you know yeah no i
know that is tough and you know as a
result i think you get to see other
people's professions and i enjoy doing
that too if you like that video where do
you see my next one don't forget to
click right over here and subscribe